Bạn đang dùng Antigravity 2.0 mà không mở được file Word,
Excel hay PowerPoint, video này dành cho bạn.
Trong video này mình sẽ show cho bạn một skill chuyển đổi tất
cả các file như là Office qua Markdown chỉ trong vài giây.
Skill này dựa trên Tool Markitdown của Microsoft được hơn 150.000
sao đánh giá ở trên GitHub. Qua về mình,
mình là Nam, Senior Software Engineer tại FIS,
top công ty fintech hàng đầu thế giới. 7 năm qua,
mình đã tự động hóa toàn bộ Workflow văn phòng của mình,
từ báo cáo cuộc họp đến quản lý team.
Sau video này, bạn có thể chuyển đổi bất kỳ các file nào như
là Word, Excel, PowerPoint, Image,
PDF sang dạng Markdown, không cần cài đặt phức tạp.
Demo skill của mình xem nó có thể làm gì nhé.
Bây giờ mình sẽ chạy xem nó hoạt động như thế nào nha. OK,
con Gemini của mình đã tự động hoàn thành xong
skill này của mình. Bây giờ mình sẽ mở cái Overview Artifact này xem
nha. OK, nó đã convert tất cả các file mà mình vừa show cho
bạn thành dạng Markdown.
Vậy Markitdown là gì? Markitdown là tool được viết bởi Microsoft, open
source trên GitHub. Mình đã có bản tóm tắt về cái tool này.
Cái tool này sẽ dùng Python để chuyển đổi mọi file như
file Office, PDF,
HTML, ảnh, audio, zip sang dạng cấu trúc Markdown sẵn sàng cho những
hệ thống AI lớn để process.
Cái này đơn giản thì nó sẽ có file đầu vào và chuyển
hóa thành Markdown output, rồi sau đó sẽ dễ
dàng hơn cho AI để xử lý. Các định dạng hỗ trợ của
cái tool này thứ nhất là Word,
Excel, PowerPoint, PDF, trang web,
hình ảnh, audio, Archive, dữ liệu và YouTube Links.
Tool này cực kỳ nhẹ, chạy trên mọi hệ điều hành như là Windows,
Mac, Linux đều được. Đây là cái tool gốc.
Mình đã chỉnh sửa thêm cái tool này một tí thành một cái skill
ở trên Antigravity 2.0 của mình đây.
Thành cái skill có tên là Markitdown.
Đơn giản là mình đã update cái skill này.
Cái skill này bây giờ, mình sẽ chỉ đơn giản là khi mình biến
nó thành cái skill, mình sẽ đưa cho một file hoặc là
folder, và cái skill này sẽ đọc tất cả các file ở trên folder
đấy, chuyển thành tất cả thành dạng Markdown rồi tinh
chỉnh làm sao cho đẹp và giống như những file mình đã input
vào. Khi làm việc với Antigravity 2.0 mà không mở được file Word
và một số file khác, mình khá là khó chịu nên mình đã tạo
skill này. OK, bạn đã biết tool này hoạt động như thế nào rồi.
Hãy demo thực tế nhé. Bây giờ mình sẽ mở Antigravity lên.
Bây giờ mình sẽ gọi cái skill của mình là Markitdown. Rồi
bây giờ mình đã chuẩn bị một folder có sẵn, có tất cả các
file như là — đây là folder mình đã chuẩn bị, có tất cả
file Word, Excel, PowerPoint hay PDF. Bây giờ mình sẽ chuyển tất cả các file
này chỉ bằng một câu lệnh, chuyển thành dưới dạng Markdown, và mình sẽ
làm việc với tất cả các file này ở trên Antigravity 2.0. Bây giờ
mình sẽ nhập input folder project. Bây
giờ mình sẽ chạy xem nó hoạt động như thế nào nha. OK,
con Gemini của mình đã tự động hoàn thành xong
skill này của mình. Bây giờ mình sẽ mở cái Overview Artifact này xem
nha. OK, nó đã convert tất cả các file mà mình vừa show cho
bạn thành dạng Markdown.
Bây giờ mình sẽ mở từng file một nha. Đây là tất cả các
file mà nó đã tạo cho mình. Đó,
đẹp và giống như file Word của mình.
Đây, mình sẽ mở file PDF đó.
Bây giờ mình sẽ làm việc ở trên những cái file này.
Giả sử là mình muốn chuyển đổi hoặc là thêm cái gì đó.
Mình sẽ làm việc ở trên cái file này, như là thay 35.000 hoặc
là sau đó. Sau khi làm xong, mình chỉ cần nói với con
AI của mình là: "Hãy cập nhật file như đã chỉnh sửa ở trên
file Markdown." Thế là nó sẽ tự động cập nhật tất cả các file
và mình không cần phải sửa file Word nữa.
Đó. Mình sẽ để skill và hướng dẫn cài đặt đầy
đủ ở trên GitHub của mình. Bạn có thể vào đó tải về và
làm theo là xong. Link ở dưới description nhé.
Vậy là bạn đã có skill chuyển đổi mọi file như file Word,
Excel, PowerPoint, Audio, Image sang dạng Markdown, không bị
kẹt với Antigravity nữa, không còn cảnh không mở được file Office và phải chuyển qua chuyển lại.
Nếu thích những video về tự động hóa kiểu này, hãy vào kênh PieLikeClaw
của mình để xem thêm nha. Hẹn gặp bạn ở những video sau.
Thank you.